In this video, we'll explore a Skeletal Mesh import pipeline.
Skeletal meshes are different from static meshes.
Like a static mesh, there is a mesh object for the visuals,
but it also has a hierarchical bone skeleton that can drive the animation of the vertices that make that mesh.
The vertices are often weighted to different bones and different amounts,
and skeletal meshes are usually used, but not always just for created animated characters and organic shapes.
And again, everything from the skeleton to the textures to the animation data and the physics body data
can be created over in your DCC tool of choice,
but Unreal Engine can often generate this on the fly and even let you edit it using the Skeletal Mesh Editor tools.
When we import a Skeletal Mesh into Unreal, if we leave the Skeleton field blank,
it will use the Skeleton that comes with the FBX file or generate one,
but we can also select an existing Skeleton if we would like to ensure that this Skeletal Mesh will conform to an existing Skeleton.
Once we have a Skeletal Mesh in our project, we can begin to animate it, and I'll show you a few different ways of doing that now.
If we open up the map called Gaunt, we'll see a Skeletal Mesh Actor imported via FBX.
We see it came with a physics asset, its skeleton, as well as textures and materials.
The physics asset again gives us a sense of how it will collide with geometry,
similar to the collisions we were looking at before, and like those collisions, this is simplified.
If we take a look at its skeleton, we can see a fairly standard set of bones here.
If we'd like to, we could visualize all the bones and even start to adjust to see how they move
and how adjusting one bone affects parents and children.
However, if we want to see this with an animation right now, we'll find that if we choose Animation Asset, nothing is available
because there are no animations set up for this particular Skeleton.
Luckily, if you recall earlier, I did bring in this Zombie Animation Pack,
and we should also have some animations from our third-person template down here, for example, Run Forward.
So there's a very robust animation retargeting pipeline in Unreal Engine now, so allow me to demonstrate that for a moment.
So I'll sort this by animation sequence, and I can just select any of these to begin, right-click,
and yes, I could do Replace Skeleton, which could give me mixed results, but I'm going to go ahead and choose Retarget Animations.
And so right now, we can see the source Skeletal Mesh for these animations is actually the UE4 Manny.
Let's stick with UE5 to keep things simple for now.
I think we can see a UE5 Manny right there, so I'll go Retarget Animations, there he is, UE5 Manny,
and the target Skeletal Mesh is going to be gone.
So we see the two standing side by side, and yes, I could do all of these animations one by one,
but to start, I'm going to export a retarget asset.
And this retarget asset, I'll put into my temp folder,
and it will create this auto-generated retargeting system that will try to match Manny's movements to Gaunt.
And if I wanted to test this briefly, I could open up any of these animations
and see how the two of them respond together to the same animations,
even though they actually have different skeletons, and we can see it's working pretty well.
Let's also try one of the more standard ones, like a walking animation,
although I guess that is a little bit zombie focused.
Another idle animation, that's an idle animation, sure.
And yes, from there, I could select any number of these animations.
I'll just do the attack ones here, and I can do export selected animations,
put them in my temp folder.
I have the option here to do some prefixes and suffixes,
and just go ahead and leave it as is, and do export.
Now I have these animations, as we can see by the thumbnails, targeted to our Gaunt character,
and I can even test them here in the editor by selecting one of them
and then going to update animation in editor.
It's looking pretty good there.
In the next video, we'll look at some future considerations for our FBX workflow.
Thank you for watching.